we've been investing in the AI for
Earth's space from a peer research
perspective for almost a decade and it
was really when Microsoft started to go
all-in an AI that there was a
conversation saying look we've been
investing this for 10 years isn't now
the time if not now then when
and so I put together a memo called AI
Firth which is how we could take this
out of research take this out of
incubation deploy it across the entire
company and then allow the full kind of
scope and scale of a Microsoft to put
that in the hands of partner
organizations all around the world
you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using we hear a
lot these days about AI for good and the
efforts of many companies to harness the
power of artificial intelligence to
solve some of our biggest environmental
challenges it's rare however that you
find a company willing to bring its
environmental bona fides all the way to
the c-suite we'll meet dr. Lucas joppa a
former environmental and computer
science researcher at MSR who was tapped
in 2017 to become the company's first
chief environmental scientist dr. Jaffa
is now the chief environmental officer
at Microsoft another first and is
responsible for managing the company's
overall environmental sustainability
efforts from operations to policy to
technology today dr. Joppa shares how
his love for nature and the joy of
discovery actually helped shape his
career path and tells us all about AI
for Earth a multi-year multi-million
dollar initiative to deploy the full
scale of Microsoft's products policies
and partnerships across four key areas
of agriculture water biodiversity and
climate and transform the way society
monitors models and ultimately manages
Earth's natural resources that and much
more on this episode of the Microsoft
Research podcast
[Music]
Lukis japa welcome to the podcast thanks
for having me you're the chief
environmental officer at Microsoft for
staff does anyone else have that or is
that unique to this company I think to
the best of my knowledge it's unique to
this company actually came from a role
that was unique to this company as well
so before I was the chief environmental
officer I was a chief environmental
scientist and as a former Microsoft
researcher I always told myself I didn't
want a job that didn't have the word
scientist in it but as long as I kept
environment in the chief environmental
officer then I'm good there are
companies that have you know chief
sustainability officers and things like
that but those generally have a much
more narrow purview to them than the
role that I currently have perhaps
within the company and the
sustainability practices of the company
or I think you know a traditional chief
sustainability officer really thinks
about sustainability within the four
walls of an organization how do you
reduce the negative environmental impact
of an organization's business practices
and I think that that is a very
important aspect of the role I call it a
wholly necessary but entirely
insufficient criterion for success in
the environmental space Microsoft's a
hundred and thirty thousand employees or
so and that's pretty small if you look
at the seven plus billion people in the
world so we've got to think about how we
take our products our policies our
partnerships and use those to really
expand our impact all around the world
we're a tech company were obsessed with
scale right that's what we need to be
seeking with sustainability as well your
title is kind of a spoiler alert to what
kind of big problems you're looking to
solve and I usually ask that kind of off
the bat but give us a virtual earth 3d
view of the work you do what gets you up
in the morning ultimately at the highest
level what gets me up in the morning is
the same thing that always has as far
back as I can remember which is just
this like kind of incredible sense of
wonder about the world I think you know
I've just always seen my place in the
cosmos and on the planet is this tiny
infinitesimal speck and just you know
I've been fascinated by what else is out
there
and as I start
to think about that more you know some
people are super interested in what's up
there up in the sky right in outer space
I was always interested in what's here
at home on planet earth and then of
course what's the human species role in
that what impact are we having how much
of that life have we discovered that's
what intrinsically gets me up I think
the thing that then gets me out of bed
and gets me to work every day is what
can we do to extend our knowledge base
how can we go out and actually
accelerate human discovery of the rest
of life on earth and then how can we use
some of our tools in our science to
mitigate the impact of our own human
activities on Earth's natural systems
because that last bit that worry about
human impact that's actually kind of
what keeps me up at night and so part of
what drives the work of researchers and
the people who work with them to bring
their efforts to life is what we don't
know that quest for discovery the quest
for knowledge so what are the big
knowledge gaps in environmental science
and how is computer science helping to
narrow those gaps just general right now
sure I think you know if you want to
couch it in the framing of the big
problem that we have right now is that
human societies ultimately facing
probably the greatest challenge human
society has ever faced what I mean by
that is we somehow have to figure out
how to adapt to and mitigate changing
climates ensure resilient water supplies
sustainably feed a human population
currently at seven growing to ten
billion people all while stemming a
catastrophic loss of biodiversity this
is going on and so what you have to do
is you have to know about all of our
systems how we use those systems to
sustain our human activities and then of
course how we can mitigate and manage
those systems to accelerate human
progress I think just one little example
that I spent a lot of time on earlier in
my research career is just looking at
for instance the number of species on
earth actually we've only scientifically
discovered something like 2 million
species scientists estimate that's
probably something like 1015 million
we've only even discovered something
like 20% that best of life on earth and
of that you know if you look at what we
actually know a lot of that discovery is
just kind of a specimen in a drawer with
you know a Latin name written on it if
you look at like how many of those
species have we actually kind of studied
and we understand their populations how
their populations are faring done kind
of a full conservation assessment for
any particular species we've done that
for about a hundred thousand species of
the potentially ten million or more that
are out there and so you know we live in
this world where you can just ask your
phone how to get to the nearest
Starbucks and it's got to run at least
cost path algorithm to find out is it
shorter to go 20 steps to the right or
30 steps to the left to get to the
nearest one that's kind of our
day-to-day problems but when you take a
step back and you ask the human position
within the rest of life on earth I mean
we talk about an information age and you
know information overload well it comes
to our understanding of environmental
systems it's a complete and total
information drought
[Music]
well let's plunge in right away
and talk about AI for earth which is a
pivotal program and one that you're
spearheading here at Microsoft the
program was launched in 2017 and at the
time they said it's a five-year 50
million dollar cross company effort to
deploy the full scale of Microsoft's AI
technologies capabilities research in
four key areas mm-hmm so let's start
macro and then we'll get micro in a bit
first give us an overview of AI for
earth why it exists and what its core
areas of focus are fundamentally AF
earth exists to change the way that
human society monitors models and
ultimately manages Earth's natural
systems that's what we're trying to do
and we're trying to take a technology
focus on doing that now when you think
about the scope and the scale of the
problem how big earth is how few people
there are for such a huge sphere and how
many species there are and how many
complex relationships you realize that
we need to find scalable mechanisms to
monitoring and modeling Earth's natural
systems and when you embedded inside the
tech sector as I've been inside the
research arm of a company like Microsoft
you realize just how rapid and
incredible the progress we're making in
collecting data analyzing data
delivering insights to users and so it
just for me became clear that Microsoft
should be focusing its attention in that
space on environmental systems and that
we should really focus on agriculture
water biodiversity and climate change
those four issues are inseparable from
each other by the way I mean obviously
yeah you need water to grow crops and
you need species to pollinate crops and
you need predictable climates to be able
to plant crops predictably and so those
all kind of bundle together under that
higher rubric of AI for Earth and this
five-year fifty million dollar
commitment to deploying Microsoft's 35
years
of research investments in the key areas
of artificial intelligence talk a little
bit more about this idea of five years
because it's not five years explain what
you mean by that
sure I mean you know anybody that works
in the tech sector understands that five
years is actually a geological age right
five years is about as far into the
future as we can possibly imagine if you
look at the research to product to
deployment cycle that's going on right
now if you quickly understand that a
five-year commitment in the tech sector
means that you're committing to
deploying technologies out into a
particular space in our case
environmental sustainability
technologies that haven't even been
invented yet I mean in some cases maybe
technologies that have even even been
dreamed of yet and so for me five years
just is really something so far off in
the horizon that it's kind of a
statement of saying as long as we can
imagine doing tech we imagine doing tech
furnature right the 50 million dollar
part is important of course but it's way
more than that because of all the other
resources that come across Microsoft and
what was really interesting is everyone
talks about the 50 million dollar
five-year commitment but nobody talks
about how we kind of launched it with a
much smaller commitment we launched it
with a two million dollar commitment
about five months prior to the main
announcement and this is what I love
about the tech sector in general
Microsoft in particular we launched it
with the two million dollar investment
just to kind of see what the demand was
the demand was overwhelming and we were
able to scale to meet it as quickly as
we saw it I think that for me just kind
of blew my mind about the power of a
large organization you can put something
out in the market you can see market and
response market demand and you can just
immediately rise up and meet it I'd been
in Microsoft research leading research
programs at the intersection
environmental and computer science
that's another thing we've been
investing in this space in the AI for
Earth's space from a peer research
perspective for almost a decade and it
was really when Microsoft from a
corporate level really started to go
all-in and hey
that there was a conversation about just
like every technology that we incubate
inside Microsoft research there's a
question about the human tech transfer
for me of saying look we've been
investing this for ten years isn't now
the time if not now then when
and so I put together a memo called AI
Firth which is how we could take this
out of research take this out of
incubation deploy it across the entire
company and then allow the full kind of
scope and scale of a Microsoft to put
that in the hands of partner
organizations all around the world we
went from nothing to something like 250
grantees working in all seven continents
60 plus countries around the world 38 or
so states in the United States for
me--for it's kind of the program
equivalent of seeing some feature that
you develop deployed in software that's
used by a billion people right you know
just to see that incredible growth and
that's because of the 35 years of
investment that we've been putting on
his face well we talked about four areas
of focus and I'd like to switch over and
talk about the three what you call
pillars of support for the program yeah
tell us about the pillars of this
program how did you decide on them why
are they important so effort from its
very beginnings had three pillars and
those pillars are super purposeful and
they were put in place as the result of
years of work in this area of
recognition of what the difficulties are
and the pillars are simply access
education and Co innovation and what I
mean by that is from an access
perspective is that most organizations
that work on environmental topics aren't
the large enterprise customers of the
world they're the small scrappy
nonprofits the chronically underfunded
government agencies the academics the
small kind of social good startups and
these are organizations where resources
are incredibly tight and they often just
don't have the ability to get out ahead
on kind of the digital transformation
journey that they would like to because
they just don't have that little bit of
excess cap
that they would need to crystallize the
process and so for me the number one
thing going into AI for Earth was just
this recognition that budget simply
cannot be a barrier to people using our
tech for environmental sustainability
and so the significant aspect of our
budget about 50 million dollars is just
to ensure that budget isn't a barrier
that anybody who's taking the end of a
machine learning or AI first approach to
solving environmental sustainability
challenges in the four areas of Ag water
biodiversity or climate we want to get
our tech in their hands that's great but
it ignores the fact that
also while resources are short most of
those places doing the best work their
employees didn't graduate from the
world's leading computer science
departments their employees graduated
from the world's leading environmental
science departments often some of our
best tech still requires a minor in
computer science to use fully
effectively you know and so we
immediately recognize that just putting
tech in people's hands that don't know
how to use it as kind of a fool's errand
you've got to ensure that you follow
that up with educational curricula and
community building and so we started
putting together things like AI firth
education summits bringing grantees from
all over the world together both in
person and digitally we've got some
fantastic top technical talent on the
team that also leads that education
effort and so engineering is an absent
from education yeah and then the last
bit is just simply a recognition of
reality which is that the tech sector
has a lot of the tech talent and that
human skill and capacity we need to be
able to put that into play as well the
thing is we know a lot about tech in a
little bit about the environment our
partners know a whole lot about the
environment and a little bit about tech
and that intersection there is where
innovation actually happens right it's
not just collaboration collaboration is
just like a me helping you get something
done or vice versa right but this idea
that there's something that comes out of
it that's greater than the sum of its
parts that's what innovation for me
means and so we looked across and those
were the three pillars obviously there's
always more to do
but AI for earth writ large has several
specific projects within that really
flesh out how this impacts the real
world tell us about these it's a lot to
cover but maybe a brief overview of each
would just give our listeners sort of
the basis for where you're heading with
this Silvia Terra is a big one
yes Silvia Terry is a fantastic
organization soviet-era is actually the
name of the company not just the project
and what they're really looking to do is
to provide a species level tree count
product across the entire United States
and this is super important because when
you think about climate change
mitigation or land conservation you have
to know what is where how much is there
and how fast is it changing and we
fundamentally don't know that
information about Earth's natural
resources or the natural resources of
the United States soviet-era is using
high-resolution satellite and aerial
imagery and convolutional deep neural
networks to be able to build up that
data product from looking down train up
models that are able to assess not just
is there a tree there or not but what
species of tree that is how big that
tree is what its carbon potential etc
etc that really is allowing people that
have kind of a an unprecedented view
into the state of their local forests
and Silvia Tara's work on single tree
species counting and identification is
just kind of a subset of a larger
problem that some of my research
colleagues and I here in MSR have been
tackling over the past couple years
which is trying to build a land cover
product so not just where are the trees
but where the forests the fields the
built in urban environments the creeks
and the streams and the lakes all of
that so that you can look down and not
just say oh that pixel is red or green
or blue or looks like a tree but we can
bring all that together for the United
States at a 1 meter resolution that's
something like ten trillion pixels that
you need to count up and it's a really
hard computer science problem as well
and so building up things like a forest
map of species a national land cover map
all of these sorts of things start to
get you towards that kind of queryable
earth that I think
all interested in if you look at you
know the way we want to answer a lot of
questions it's kind of from looking down
at the world and satellite imagery and
the size of these data sets you know
we're talking about just petabytes and
petabytes and petabytes of data flowing
down and so you've got to store those
data you've got to be able to get them
into memory really quick you know you've
got to be able to train up algorithms
really efficiently and then you've got
to be able to do evaluation or deploy
those algorithms over even larger
amounts of data it's a super non-trivial
task getting those data labelled I mean
is just a problem in of itself and so
you know when people ask why environment
I mean even if you didn't care about an
environment from a computer science
perspective these are some of the
hardest problems out there talk a little
bit give a nod to farm beats and project
premonition because those are two really
cool things that are going on I've
watched those projects farm beats and
project premonition grow from ideas to
what they are right now I mean farm
beats an incredible sensor and data
fusion project that's really looking to
revolutionize the way that farmers
collect data about their field and make
harvesting and growing decisions based
on extremely new advances in artificial
intelligence bringing that all together
I mean it's it's kind of crazy to see
the results of some of these projects
because ultimately it kind of distills
down to some graphs on a browser
dashboard right and what that hides is
just the incredible amount of
engineering of actual physical
electronic sensors in the field
communicating over really novel
communication pathways like TV white
space which were on vir is such an
incredible kind of advocate and
proponent for bringing that into
centralized on-prem compute centers
figuring out what matters what needs
bigger compute doing all of that kind of
local intelligence processing sending up
information and data sets to our larger
compute clusters in the cloud and
ultimately just allowing somebody to
come click and see what's going on out
in their field just from you know
balloons floating in the air drones
flying around in sensors out there it's
kind of incredible and Ethan another
fantastic researcher in Microsoft
Research he's really interested in how
we monitor the biosphere as he would say
and his kind of path into it is through
understanding that we have a scale
problem he originally started out
wanting to understand diseases and how
we can prevent epidemics with this
perspective that epidemics are so
catastrophic because we don't see them
coming right and they often come from
our unbuilt natural environments and
they're housed by the rest of life on
Earth and so if you want to go out and
sample that well you need to take a
technology approach but still tech isn't
gonna allow you to sample every animal
on the planet everywhere but he had the
same simple idea that many have had
before him which is that evolution has
already provided these data samplers in
the form of biting insects mosquitoes
and they're kind of devilish ilk right
and so the question is well how do you
insert yourself in that data sampling
process Pierre meta-genome assess you
see mosquitoes in the blood samples they
collect is simply roaming data
collectors so now you need to figure out
how to collect those data and the
engineering that Ethan his team have put
together and building these entirely new
next-generation mosquito traps that are
running machine learning algorithms on
board that can do species level
recognition from wingbeat frequency
patterns decide which species they want
to collect and then pipe those into a
full metagenomics compute engine that
again spits out some graphs and
information about what diseases and
other species might be out in that
environment you know the scope and the
scale it's it's you know somebody who
speaks about these a lot one of the
things that I really struggle to get
across it seems just this horrible
disservice to this entire legacy of
research and innovation that goes into
providing something so simple and so
powerful that people just don't see
everything that goes behind it right and
I think that's kind of one of the cool
things about the digital transformation
that the world is undergoing is all of
the incredibly useful applications that
we have in our
that make our lives lighter but are
powered by things that most people will
never be capable of truly kind of
grokking you know the scope and the
scale of work that goes into this stuff
I love that you said their word grok
it's one of my favorite words
that's a sci-fi word that's right I
think we get why the earth part of this
program is important but let's talk a
bit more about the AI part what does AI
do for the earth that we can't I think
we framed this in a previous
conversation as an efficiency story but
agreed that that doesn't quite do it
justice yeah I mean I think the way I
look at it is like ultimately we've got
this massive scale problem on the size
of the earth the amount of living
organisms on earth the complexity of
their relationships so there's this
massive scale problem how do we scale
and then we have a resource problem
which is that the organizations that
focus on this for better or worse aren't
necessarily the most well resourced
organizations in the world and so where
has tech always had a transformative
impact it's in the efficiency story and
what is efficiency well efficiency
allows you to either do the same for
less or do more for the same and maybe
in the enterprise space when you're
worrying about margins and quarterly
profits you're really interested in
doing at the very least the same for
less and maybe even more for less but
when you're interested in understanding
the rest of life on Earth when you're
interested in collecting data about
natural systems and building models
about them and your wildly
resource-constrained the question you're
asking yourself every day is how do i do
orders of magnitude more for the same
and technology allows you to do that one
nice story from a partner organization
between the AI first program Microsoft
Research and a small nonprofit called
the Chesapeake Bay Conservancy this is
that land cover mapping project and you
know we had this ambition to build a 1
meter resolution land cover map for the
entire United States that's plowing
through something like ten trillion
pixels 2530 terabytes of data
and that was an aspiration shared with
this small k-19 person nonprofit called
Chesapeake Bay Conservancy and they were
way out ahead of us mind you because
they actually had done stuff and we just
thought about it and what they had done
was they had built a 1 meter resolution
land cover map for the Chesapeake Bay
watershed which is just a small fraction
of the United States but it had taken
them well over a million dollars and
over a year and a half just to produce
that one data product and so that meant
that by the time they got done they were
almost already out of date right and so
we came in we said hey look you know the
way you're doing that we think that
there's a better way it turned out to be
really hard it's led to some top papers
and you know leading conferences like
cvpr and ICL are and you know we've made
some significant machine learning
progress as well but ultimately we still
have a long way to go on our algorithm
that kind of accuracy side of things but
from just a pure infrastructure
perspective we're able to train up an
algorithm and deploy it on a cluster of
800 FPGAs so field programmable gate
arrays which is some really cool
architecture that we've been shipping
all across Asia and plow through all ten
trillion pixels so go from the
Chesapeake Bay to the entire United
States 25 terabytes of data 10 trillion
pixels 10 minutes $42 so that gets to
how do I do more for the same or in this
case way more for way less and so that's
just the efficiency story how do you
give an individual or a small
organization superpowers you either give
them a huge check or you give them
technology
[Music]
several researchers on the pod have
talked about this idea of humans in the
loop and it kind of speaks to the fact
that technology isn't taking us over it
still needs us if we personify it but
you've turned that on its head a little
bit talk to me about your take on who's
in the loop and how and why yeah I mean
I think what's kind of funny is you know
researchers are always so far out ahead
that they started talking about humans
in the loop probably two decades before
it was relevant they were talking about
humans of the loop when we were still
trying to figure out how to put
algorithms in the loop right where we
were doing most of it but algorithms
were just kind of helping I think where
a lot of the worry is coming from an AI
and ethics perspective or anything else
is around what the future might hold
when we need to purposefully build
humans into the loop so then we have
these spot checks and balances and
things like that
so I still think we completely live in a
world where it's algorithms in the loop
of human activity algorithms in the loop
of human life that's the world I want to
live in I don't want to live in a world
where it's humans in the loop as if I'm
some sort of secondary citizen - yeah
addendum to this digital substrate that
I'm just you know allowed to exist in
you know it's kind of a corollary to
something else that just frustrates me
all the time which is that so many of
the things that we don't know about are
things that we ourselves have built so
ask me where all the world's dams are I
don't know ask me where all the world's
roads are we built these things and we
don't even know where they are with the
state of them and so when you get back
to this whole human-in-the-loop concept
I fundamentally have a problem with
imagining a future where I'm an addendum
to something that we built and just to
prove how far off I think we are from
that is that the things we built as I
said like are kind of addendums in our
lives still and I think we'd be much
better focused in figuring out how to
put algorithms in
to help us understand what we've built
the impact that it's having on
environmental and social systems and to
build our societies around that and
that's gonna be really important as we
start to ask algorithms what we should
do about managing Earth's natural
systems where should we put renewable
versus non-renewable energy where should
we put high-density urban growth centers
versus protected areas and national
parks where should we do you know any
number of things well we don't know
enough about our own biology to tell an
algorithm how we'd make that decision
and we don't know enough about
algorithms to understand fully why
they'd make that decision so I think
there just needs to be this awareness of
like you know what once the output comes
out if it feels right to me if it looks
good to me then I'm gonna continue to
interrogate it with human systems and
I'm gonna take it one step at a time but
that's just my opinion when I asked you
what gets you up in the morning you
basically said it was the wonder of it
all the wonder of discovery but we've
hit the worry part of the podcast this
is where I ask the guests what keeps you
up at night and aside from all the
concerns about conservation and
stewardship of our planet you're
developing and deploying some incredibly
powerful technologies in which we're
putting a lot of trust what could
possibly go wrong hmm well I mean what
keeps me up at night is both what could
possibly go wrong and and that we won't
do it fast enough
my former manager and longtime mentor
Eric Horvitz who leads Microsoft
Research you know he has a long history
in the health space at the intersection
of health and medicine and machine
learning and one of the things that he
consistently says is people worry about
the issues of algorithms in these loops
and that's completely valid and
understandable but what's the human cost
of not doing it I think that same thing
is true in the environmental space which
is just the opportunities are so
incredible to help better understand and
manageress natural systems that we have
got to be throwing basically
everything that we have at it so my
first worry is that we won't
my first worry is that all the other
tech companies won't follow Microsoft's
lead and build up an AI firth program
that all of the environmental scientists
and organizations won't see tech as one
of the significant breakthrough
solutions in their space and that will
stagnate we won't make the progress that
we all know we need to make so that's
the first thing that keeps me up at
night there's that secondary worry which
is what could go wrong well I mean if
history shows you anything about human
activities is that a whole lot could go
wrong I you know I worry more about our
lack of understanding of how nature
works and doing something that
inadvertently as a bit of a
Schrodinger's cat kind of a fact in the
sense of like are you observing what
would have been observed in the absence
of observation right I don't actually
know if that's what Schrodinger said or
not but it sounded good something about
a dead cow something about it yeah or
something about the two cats in a box so
that's really kind of one of the first
design principles for everything that we
do is in the absence of full
understanding do you feel like you are
really taking that like do no harm
kind of approach and that's one of the
reasons that we're really interested in
these kind of aspects of remote
monitoring whether that's like taking
images from above or a you know
passively listening to ecosystems with
acoustic sensors or monitoring
environmental systems through the lens
of organism like a mosquito that many
places are trying to eradicate anyway
and really thinking about are we
deploying technology in a way that isn't
going to further disrupt the system
because the reason we're putting
technology in the system is to figure
out how to fix it and stop the problems
and so those are my two worries you know
I work a lot so the time between
worrying falling asleep and wondering
and waking up and getting going again is
a bit too short so I'm sometimes I feel
like those two w's go hand-in-hand so I
like to hear the stories of the guests
that come on this show personal
professional
academic how you ended up doing what
you're doing how did you get started and
how did you end up doing what you're
doing now you know I grew up the kid
that just loved being out in the woods
never was a technology kind of family
I've never had a TV didn't have a
computer until undergrad never learned
how to program until my PhD when I
realized that I probably should but I
was always just interested in how it
kind of all worked and then I started
paying more attention to the fact that
in many cases it wasn't working
ie humans were negatively influencing
these systems did my undergrad in
wildlife ecology one of the beauties of
the American education system is the
general education requirements I took a
general education requirement called on
the extinction of species I sat through
that first class I listened to this
professor talk about the state of the
world and I was just completely and
totally hooked to change my major spent
two years in the Peace Corps saw some of
these environmental issues just kind of
raw up front in person came back to my
PhD in ecology and environmental science
that's when I really leaned into tech
because I realized that there was no way
I was going to answer the questions that
I wanted to ask like to protected areas
protect well there's a lot of protected
areas all around the world you want to
ask that across the entire earth across
every year you're gonna be running code
to do those sorts of things and just
through kind of serendipity and contacts
ended up at Microsoft Research in
Cambridge in the UK I had an incredible
time there and now I have this
opportunity to oversee Microsoft's
global sustainability ambitions
everything from our built environments
to our technology deployment it's kind
of a crazy thing to look back and see
from a kid in the woods to where you sit
now among the trees here in Redmond all
right Lucas as I said at the beginning
of the podcast
you're the chief environmental officer
at Microsoft here's your chance to say
whatever you want to our listeners I
haven't framed this in terms of parting
thoughts wisdom advice inspiration but
you can say anything you want
so go I get asked this question a lot
and the thing that I always say is
don't take the easy path which is what
do you need to succeed and it's easy to
say I need money or I need resources but
when I'm talking to an audience like
this an audience of machine learning
experts computer science professionals
and researchers all around the world the
message I try to consistently deliver is
all I really need is for every single
person at some point in the day to think
about how they could deploy their core
competency to just think about hey you
know what I'm a homomorphic encryption
guy or I'm a deep neural Nets person or
I'm a UI UX person that's what I'm great
at now how can i deploy that to help
make progress in one of these massive
areas of societal challenge how can I
think about accelerating human progress
in the areas of Ag water biodiversity
and climate change if you just think
about that even if you don't have an
idea today or tomorrow if you just think
about that every day and then I'm
satisfied then we've made an incredible
start on the problem
I don't need every single person to pick
up an identical brick I need every
person to commit to doing what they're
good at I think so many people look and
they say in environmental sustainability
oh well we need is better policy you go
over to the public sector and they said
well we need our technology solutions
and the truth is we need all of that and
we need the people who are best at each
of those things to do what they're best
at the Microsoft's of the world need to
contribute tech the public sector needs
to contribute policy and you know
double-click all the way down in the
tech sector to whatever kind of role
that you have in a company like
Microsoft that's what the world needs
the world needs what you're best at
deployed to help solve some of these
environmental challenges Lukas joppa
thank you for coming on the podcast yeah
thank you so much for having me it's a
huge pleasure and a great opportunity
to learn more about dr. Lucas Joppa and
how Microsoft is putting its powerful
cloud and AI tools into the hands of
those working to solve environmental
challenges visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]